nicolas vidal bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin alors les débats à
l'assemblée nationale on l'a dit ont
duré plus longtemps que prévu qu est ce
qui a particulièrement posé problème
dans ce texte
ah ben moi je vous le dis bien
aujourd'hui ce matin je suis absolument
abasourdi par la teneur des débats par
la rapidité des débats une information
obtenue entre cette nuit entre 1h du
matin à six heures du matin ou 5h43 être
précis il ya eu 400 amendements qui ont
été discutés enfin discuter à la va vite
ce matin c'est un goût très sincèrement
de discrimination officialisé
institutionnalisée une marche absolument
forcée vers ce passé iter vous l'avez
dit se passer ni terre énergie mais
aussi on a marché sur quoi on a marché
aujourd'hui sur la souveraineté des
français et ce matin j'ai quand même un
peu l'impression qu'on est en train de
dériver vers un autoritarisme où la
discrimination je le dis est devenu
absolument officiel je terminerai par là
pour cette première question
concrètement c'est une atteinte
incroyable aux libertés fondamentales
les plus essentiels des français pierre
est en fait c'est toute notre démocratie
qui est en train de péricliter
suite à ces débats qui ont duré on le
dit une journée demi une journée de vite
prendre texte aussi important pour un
test un texte aussi liberticide
un texte très élargi et nous rentrons
dans le détail de ce texte vous parliez
tout à l'heure de 400 amendements qui
ont été débattus rapidement cette nuit
plus de mille amendements ont été
déposés justement sur sur ce texte
il aura fallu des mois pour pour tous
les examiner avec bien entendu bien
entendu mais j'ai pu dire quelque chose
la question de fond qui se posent
aujourd'hui c'est la question de la
démocratie si la démocratie elle ne sert
que dans un pays serein apaisé et que
finalement en temps de crise on passe
dessus et d'un quoi elle sert la
démocratie c'est juste un cadeau bonus
dans une grande boîte de lessive
aujourd'hui ces textes là il aurait
fallu un moment donné vous l'avez dit
avoir des débats déjà médiatique ça
aurait été pas mal et puis avoir des
débats très longs
d'ailleurs les députés l'opposition les
quelques députés de l'opposition se sont
insurgés sur la rapidité des bars et je
vous le rappelle les textes le
gouvernement voulait que le texte soit
voté par cette nuit à minuit
mais la nuit d'avant à minuit vous vous
rendez compte en moins d'une
on est passés 1200 amendements des
abonnements qui sont absolument scélérat
pour certains absolument scélérat donc
là on s'assoit sur la démocratie sous
couvert de crise sanitaire mais pierre
nous sommes aujourd'hui au delà d'une
crise sanitaire
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans une crise
politique majeure avec un gouvernement
qui passe en force qu'il a toujours fait
de passer en force rappelez vous la
grande forme les retraites rappelez-vous
le legi les jeunes raté vous tout ça et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve là dedans et
sur quelque chose qui va très chichement
attenter à la liberté 2 millions de
français aujourd'hui c'est peut-être 20
millions de français vous le savez
entraîneur maxime et et et les vacciner
mais aujourd'hui la question qui veut se
faire si un autre regard différent entre
les démocrates
il est non démocrates voilà ce que je
pense aujourd'hui cette première
impression dès potron minet de ceux de
secours débats à l'assemblée nationale
et dans le détail nicolas vidal qu'est
ce qui vous pose problème exactement
dans ce texte
ah bin là il y en a une qui formidable
une qui est formidable
hier les députés ont voté contre l'axé
contre le passé du fait d'avoir le passé
car pour accéder aux établissements de
santé et aux ehpad pour les patients non
urgents et des accompagnants et ben non
eh ben non ebel ans a été votée et
olivier vers en cette nuit à 5 heures du
matin avant le café croissants a fait
revoter parce qu'apparemment le vote ne
lui convenait pas surtout gouvernement
est pas qu olivier ferrand donc
finalement ça a été ça a été remis en
place vous imaginez aujourd'hui il
faudra un pass sanitaires pour aller
voir un prof ou même si vous même vous
êtes touchés par la maladie ou un
problème médical
vous devez avoir un pass à lutter pour
accéder à l'hôpital mais qu'est ce que
c'est ce pays mais qu'est ce que c'est
c'est ce débat citoyen avec un vote
il ya des choses absolument incroyable
là dessus c'est la fin d'une liberté
déplacement c'est la fin du secret
médical
donc tout ça est absolument incroyable
un autre exemple j'ai écouté hier parce
que j'étais tout la journée les débats
bien entendu pour voir un peu ce qui se
passait en tant que citoyen même au delà
de journalistes et sur la question du
transport
pierre y avez vous savez le passé iter
n'est pas obligatoire dans les ter et
les transilien tous les moyens locaux de
destination proximité mais dans le tgv
et olivier veyrat et cette explication
formidable qu'on ya posé cette question
certains députés de la majorité certains
footeux l'opposition pardon ils ont posé
cette question il
il a dit finalement oui vous comprenez
sur les tgv quand il s'agira de courtes
distances le passé militaire ne sera pas
demandée
mais dans quel monde vit-on mais dans
quel monde vit-on saurait tenir en savez
si ç'avait été un théâtre de boulevard
voyez vous mais là ce n'est pas un
théâtre de boulevard et ça va être
inscrit dans la loi bon il ya de cela
bien entendu qui va se saisir du texte
aujourd'hui mais six amendements sur
absolument incroyable emmanuel ménard
est également qui a posé un amendement
concernant la fin l'abrogation du passé
ni terre en fin de crise épidémique
il a été rejeté pourquoi certains
manquements et et ils étaient rejetés
donc vous voyez bien que moment donné on
n'est pas moi ce que j'ai noté hier sur
les débats c'est que le gouvernement n'a
pas écouté l'opposition satie et une
chose il n'était pas dans une esprit de
concorde ils étaient apparemment membres
et pour ajuster pour modifier pour moins
emmerdé les français comme l'a dit
d'ailleurs en conseil ministériel révélé
par nos confrères de libération et hier
matin proposer aux français non vaccinés
une vie de merde le gouvernement a
rejeté tout en bloc et temps il ya eu
effectivement ce seul amendement qui est
allé contre l'addiction gouvernement il
a été votée cette nuit à 5 heures du
matin c'est s'asseoir délibérément sur
la démocratie et sur la souveraineté du
peuple français et moi je suis très
inquiet et je vous le dire je me disais
en préambule je suis abasourdi est
vraiment inquiet pour ce qui va se
passer dans les prochains les prochains
jours et les prochaines semaines pour
pour nous français merci beaucoup
nicolas vidal d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin sur rtl france rappelle que vous
êtes éditorialistes merci beaucoup